in Nelson BC a city of just 10 000 an
entire Community is devastated one of
its police officers 43 year old Wade
titamore is dead another officer is
seriously injured after the two were
Swept Away in an avalanche I heard about
it last night and you know it's
obviously incredibly tragic the two
off-duty members were skiing near casla
when they were struck by the slide
Nelson's police chief says both were
wearing beacons which helped locate 28
year old officer methu nolay who was
carried into a tree the way he hit it he
kind of came back up a bit so they had
one arm up out of the snow so he told me
today like he uh he's certain you know
obviously the the the impact of the tree
caused a significant number of his
injuries but it also probably saved his
life both officers came to the community
from the Calgary Police Service which
issued a statement saying we are deeply
saddened about the passing of constable
titamore we are wishing a speedy
recovery to Constable no lay titamore
leaves behind a wife and two young Sons
Wade was a true gentleman just a very
soft spoken but uh you know he he had
um you know he knew how to deal with
situations when he needed to but uh that
was 99 of the time his
soft-spoken gentleman approach dealt
with any issues that we had to deal with
in the public
he was a great mentor so the officers in
the department
you know truly one of those guys that
everybody looked up to everybody really
liked him only about 20 officers served
the city of Nelson which is now getting
help from nearby RCMP detachments Nelson
is one of the smallest cities in the
country to have its own Municipal Police
Force and this tragedy has hit his heart
professional assistance is being offered
to Nelson's grieving police officers
also giving them support members of this
tightly knit Community all of whom have
been greatly impacted by this tragedy
Catherine urquhart Global News